this is a production of Cornell
University
morning everyone my name is Matt Ryan
I'm a assistant professor of sustainable
cropping systems at Cornell and I want
to talk with you about two strategies
that I'm working on cover crop
interceding and perennial greens and I'm
really talking about keeping the soil
covered this is a key strategy for
improving soil health and so just some
issues that I'd like to bring up your
annual green crop production often
degrades so especially when we're using
soil tillage we know that cover crops
can help offset this predation and
improve soil health but not widely
adopted so in New York based on 2014
data we're about at 10% adoption of
cover crops across all the cropland in
New York so a solution here is cover
crop interceding and so you saw a
similar picture earlier this is a cover
crop that was drill interceded into
between rows of corn and what's really
exciting about this is that people have
been interceding cover crops for a very
long time they've been aerial seeding
broadcast seeding this is a new piece of
equipment that that actually drills the
scene improves the seed to soil contact
so it makes a small slit and it deposits
the seed right into the soil surface
there and this is a cover crop mixture
there's a lot of interest and excitement
about cover crop mixtures and so
traditionally in New York on when we
were cover cropping we would typically
be limited to cereal rye cereal rye is a
great cover crop this is a standby cover
crop it's been used by thousands and
thousands of farmers for a very long
time but it's limited in the functions
that it provides it's great for cycling
nutrients and using it and using it as a
touch prop to prevent nutrient leaching
but it's that's about all it does it
provides a lot of biomass if you let it
grow and so what we're seeing here with
cover crop interceding is is that you
can actually get legumes established and
so these legumes when you get these
leggings established and other species
that you typically not be able to see it
after a cover crops are or after cash
crops are harvested in the fall it can
really change the whole
sustainability of your system and
increase Oh help dramatically so when we
survey farmers and we talk with farmers
they say that not being able to do that
their number one reason why they do not
grow cover crops is because they don't
have enough time after crop harvest in
the fall and by doing this you can get
that cover crop established on time and
actually grow these different species
and integrate them into your cropping
systems so very exciting research going
on at Cornell and across the u.s. with
cover crop interceding and we're now
starting to see that they they do have
an impact we are seeing a fairly rapid
response in terms of soil improvement
there's a recent paper that came out was
showing after just four years with cover
crop initiating we're starting to see
indicators improved indicators of soil
health so over a very short period of
time we're not necessarily increasing
soil carbon but we're starting to see
these indicators like improved soil
respiration increase aggregate stability
increase active carbon you know these
levels are going up so very exciting
research there the other strategy that
I'd like to talk about is perennial
grains so all the greens that we eat now
their annual crops right so we we till
and we replant them every year and what
we're trying to do is develop perennial
grain crops these are crops that you
would plant once and then harvest for
multiple years so this is an
illustration here just showing what you
would typically see on on the Left with
an annual crop production on sloped land
where you have some runoff and you're
getting creating some erosion and and
water quality challenges by keeping the
soil covered okay with a perennial crop
or multiple years we're thinking that we
can improve water infiltration increased
soil soil health and get more of that
water going into the soil and less of it
running off and causing erosion and
water quality problems so in New York
State we're working with the number of
farmers poor organic farmers in
particular that about we're working with
very closely growing some different
perennial grain crops one of them is
called Carranza this is a perennial
green I have some seed go right here
it's a very small seed and this is a
crop that is domesticated we're working
with
partners at the land Institute in Kansas
also in France and across across the US
but this crop um again it's it's it's
different and all of your other green
crops it's it's new and so we've taken a
wild plant and have domesticated it and
then through a recurrent selection have
selected for increased seed size and so
um what's really exciting about this is
that right now we're at a tipping point
with perennial grain production where
we're seeing large companies become
interested in turns up for increasing
their sustainability of their operations
so one company is Patagonia provisions
this is Patagonia the clothing company
they've started a line a food line and
they've started to offer a beer called
long route ale that's grown with are
made with trends oh that's 15 percent
currency in it and now General Mills
Cascadian farms is very interested and
integrating currency into their product
lines they have a new cereal that would
be coming out this October that has
occurrences in it and so I'm really
exciting stuff happening right now in
New York with our farmers we're into our
second year of harvesting again the
yields are low we're having some
challenges with harvesting this is a new
crop unlike all the other annual grains
that are completely dry when you go to
harvest this one is still a bit green so
actually getting through the combine and
working out some of these logistical
challenges mechanical problems is what
we're focused on we're also very
interested in developing agronomic
recommendations trying to figure out
when you should see this what your
seeding rate should be what your
fertility management should be so that's
all part of this research that we're
doing and you can see on the the far
right there this is a picture of the
root of this crop so on the on the Left
here the preen
green turns I and it has that extensive
root system and so that's one of the
reasons why it's in addition to keeping
the soil covered that's another reason
why it we think that it can have a major
impact and improve soil health so like I
said I think this is an up-and-coming
crop there's still more work to be done
but I keep an eye out for this and I'm
happy to talk more about this we have
time later so thank you very much this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu